- I'm here with sports broadcast
all-star, Erin Andrews!
Give it up!
(audience cheering)
I stole that from a girl
you're about to meet.
All right, it's time to play
The Balls of Sports game.
(upbeat music)
First, we need a host. Voice of God,
do you have a few minutes please?
- [God] For Kelly
Clarkson and Sports Ball?
Of course. And hello, Erin Andrews.
- Hi. It's like the Wizard of Oz.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
God, He loves our show.
So God, can you explain the game?
- [God] Well, there's very
little I can't do, Kelly.
- Okay.
- [God] You see, in this game, you win
by getting three squares
in a row on that big board
you see there, like tic-tac-toe.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [God] Now to win a square,
you throw a sports ball
through the matching sports square.
Then, you'll get a
question about that sport.
Now, if you get it right,
you win the square.
But if you get it wrong,
the other person wins the square because,
well, that's how life
works sometimes, don't it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [God] Now you and Erin
will alternate turns, okay?
Now Kelly, since you paid
me off before the show,
why don't you go first?
- Okay, I had to take my shoes
off, because that's real.
- [Erin] Sorry, Micah, I'm doing it too.
(crosstalk)
- [God] Please remove your shoes.
- [Erin] Done.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay, shoes are done.
I'm about to get destroyed, God,
and you know this because I
know nothing about sports balls,
so can I call in some help please?
- [God] Hey, it's my
world, but it's your show.
You do you, girl.
- All right, all right!
Well, let's call it my Sports Ball Posse.
This is my real posse
who loves Sports Ball,
my sister Alisa, and my
friends, Tricia, Alli and Ava.
Whoo!
(audience cheering)
- You get a team?
- Yes, I do, and y'all
can thank the lovely Ava
for my always and annoying--
(Kelly makes honking noise)
because she does it all the time.
All right, so--
- [God] All right, let's
calm down now, Kelly.
- I'm excited God!
- [God] I understand.
Let's rein it in here
and pick your square.
- Okay, pick my square.
What should I pick, y'all?
What do you think I should pick?
- [Sports Ball Posse together] Football.
- Football.
- Come on!
- [Kelly] That was like,
obviously! They were like, okay.
I'm running up here, I
can't do anything like that.
There we go, okay.
- [God] There it is.
- Okay.
- [God] Okay, and here is your question.
- [God] What NFL team has only
a single Super Bowl victory
which they won in 2018 at Super Bowl 52?
(buzzer dings)
- [Kelly] Posse?
- It was the Eagles!
- The Eagles, final answer.
- Eagles! Final answer!
- [God] All right, press
that buzzer, lock it in.
- Eagles, final answer!
(bell dings)
- That is correct.
It is the Eagles.
- Okay! I literally was
there and I don't remember.
- [God] Erin, it's your turn.
- Oh, God!
- Okay, I'm picking. All right. Oh man.
- [God] Come on, now, time's running out.
- All right, all right, all
right. I'll do basketball.
- [God] That's it. There
you go, come on, get it.
- What a cute little pencil skirt number.
(Erin cheers)
- [God] Okay, that's all right.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
- [God] The question is, what
is the name of the Duke Men's
basketball coach?
(buzzer dings)
- Mike Krzyzewski, coach K, yes.
- Oh, I was like--
(bell dings)
- [God] That is correct.
- My next question, you spell it.
No, you don't have to.
- No, I was going to say, "K." (laughs)
- [God] All right, Kelly.
- I'm doing baseball!
(Posse cheers indistinctly)
- [God] There it is.
All right, here's your question.
In what year did the Atlanta Braves
most recently win the World Series?
- Oh my God.
- These are the hardest questions.
(all shouting)
- You love baseball!
- It was in the 90s, right?
- '94, '96.
- It wasn't 94.
- How do you know?
- 96!
(bell dings)
(incorrect buzzer sounds)
- [God] I'm sorry, that is incorrect.
The answer was 1995.
(bell dings)
- Ah, I was going to say '95!
(all shouting)
- So close.
All right, Erin, go ahead
now, it's your turn.
You get to--
- Well, I would have to say volleyball,
but I'm going to get it wrong,
because I don't know
anything about volleyball.
- Well then I think you should
pick volleyball. (laughs)
- [God] Boom. There you go, all right.
And here is your question.
- Oh God.
- What tasty buttermilk
breakfast entree usually served
with maple syrup is also a volleyball move
where a player falls to
the floor in an attempt
to save the ball?
(buzzer dings)
- Pancake?
(bell dings)
- That is correct!
- [Kelly] I knew that one!
I actually knew that one,
I thought it was gonna be a person.
- I think I win!
(congratulatory music)
- [God] You do!
(all cheering)
Look at that, unbelievable.
How does it feel, Kelly?
- Let me tell you how I feel.
Loser! Loser! Loser! Loser! (laughs)
Okay, good game, we're all
good sports ball people here,
sports team-- what is it?
Sportsmanship, sportsmanship,
all the sports words.
As a reward, your portrait
will be mounted alongside
very few others on the Blake
Shelton Wall of Champions
for beating Kelly Clarkson, that's hot.
You're welcome.
- Super hot.
- Thank you so much for playing again.
So everyone out there can watch
on all your favorite devices
like Roku, Amazon, Fire TV,
iPhone, and many others.
And be sure to check out
Erin clothing line, WEAR,
which we should have all
been wearing today, what?